hey Jun really off - oh you know just
some bathroom stuff you know changing
the tamp and whatnot yeah for a second
there I thought you were gonna do number
two it wasn't the boss well as we slide
to your presentation today I heard if it
goes well you might mean for a promotion
oh yeah you know I may be so are you
leaving the bathroom anytime soon oh I
wanted to show you something at my desk
no I'm gonna saying here in the sense of
emails white boys way better enhance
time Oh in the bathroom oh that makes so
much sense something well I'll see you
later I guess yeah
doo doo doo ba doo bee doo Bao that
[ __ ] what's wrong
Nina's poop blocking me my god
why would she do that she knows what
she's doing if I'm too shy to poop
before that meeting I'll forget my
presentation that's horrible
we can't let her do this I don't know
what else to do she's blocked me at
every single bathroom wait there's a
bathroom near the basement of the annex
that no one knows about we can sneak you
in and she would never know Sam that she
is you know are you gonna tell me why
you have a map of bathrooms on your desk
no don't worry about that agent sandwich
is eagle in sight affirmative I thought
we agreed I would go by didn't sandwich
Sam I don't have time for this just make
sure Nina doesn't leave before I find
the staff you copy that hey Sam where's
Jun
I don't know Nina she's probably
prepping for a presentation like it's
any of your business all right I won't
see you and your little friend
no one poops in this office without me
knowing no matter where she goes I will
find her well good luck cuz it'll be a
miracle if you find this bathroom Sam I
found the bathroom Nina can suck it her
and her puny brain will never think to
look in the basement cap hmm well what
do you know a miracle
home
Wow
this place is beautiful never she wants
you to scare you is easy to find ever
amount of anything we'll see about that
nice work in that I underestimated you
come on you guys let's go to this
meeting at the end of the day it didn't
matter what happened behind the bathroom
stall everybody poops and there's no
reason to feel weird or ashamed about
any of it I poop
she poops he poops we all poop and we
won't make any progress in this world
unless we learn to put together